vu ça peut commencer avec un peu de
retard mais ça devrait ça devrait se
lancer
on croirait à tout le monde à tout ce
qui arrive
le stress le stress est présent bien
évidemment alors est-ce que c'est déjà
parti le match n'ont pas encore un peu
de ce cas ça comme je vous disais on va
voir si la prépa si la prépa passe j'ai
écrit un petit mot
ça tarde
rage est donc là
vous dire ça rang de star en tant qu
avec les noirs je vous ai dit ce qu'on
avait prévu sap qui est en train de
finir son roquettes ligue 1
il faut tout donner
il ya une grosse préparait il ya une
il est encore sur quatre ligues sarde
non il a quitté roquettes
on va
à la quitte mais il est sur les échecs
on va regarder le truc officiel j'ai
commencé sarde loupé rendant une
scandinave
ça va être compliqué d'entrer en
scandinave d'un dea ludique sur sur le
high tech en train de regarder avec mon
téléphone je vous invite à suivre en
même temps les stream d2 streamera que
ce soit lui de vigousse ardoz si vous
souhaitez avoir l'expérience totale
il se sent pas du tout moi je le sens
bien d'avoir hockey
j'ai un peu stressé quoi un peu comme
avant comme avant a un regard de
tchatche com c'est extraordinaire comme
avant ce battle ou quoi quand même on a
on a fait beaucoup d'efforts pour qu'il
en arrive là on a beaucoup bossé et donc
il ya envie de ja envie envie envie
qu'ils fassent ce qu'ils fassent le
résultat après après ça va être chaud
vous laisse vous laisse aller choper
l'heure
à main sur leur stream un respectif
sentiers l'âge mais on va on peut on
peut se le mette vite fait
mal de pression côté côté sarde voilà
les oasis la prépa il va rentrer à la
prépare entre à l'ego la prépa
si la prépare entre il va il va se
mettre en confiance
il faut que le match commence il va se
mettre en confiance je suis super
impatient mais ça avec ludwig et plus et
plus de dents entre guillemets il semble
qu'ils sont plus déterminés ça n'est
plus sous pression
j'espère qu'il va réussir à à évacuer
ses émotions
je suis très confiant vraiment
bien se passer bien se passer ne
t'inquiète pas c'est bien
pezens rachat s'est vite aller regarder
un peu ce le stream de ce hard ou là il
trouve pas un truc simple aller dans ce
sens ça sent quand même le stress des
deux côtés ça va être bouillant les amis
si ça va partir une petite pub
il fait des pauses à la demie du match
comme ça ouais nan mais la raison ça
détend les forains
marquise heinz ont demandé à l'accueil
lui dit que c'est trop loin il mérite sa
quissac là il ya un peu une tête une
tête à claques a entre guillemets un et
c'est ça qui fait son charme aussi un
c'est ça qui fait le serait le charme
aussi du streamer américain c'est ça qui
arma wayne il fait le malin fait le
malin à fond alors que ça
nous allons avec tripoli annonce à trash
talk et où c'est marrant donc
demandez un sulky partent c'est terrible
c'était
c'est assez terrible ça troll c'est quoi
ça trash talk sévère et bah écoutez
c'est marrant ça met un peu dangereux
mais ils dissimulent en faisant en
faisant le onze ans de rigolo il a lâché
les insultes en français aussi rêve
c'est assez dire c'est du show les amis
en faut pas prendre ça premier degré
allez on va
à ce qu'on a appris apa
a marché ou pas non mais tranquille bien
sûr c'est du second degré il sera aidé
c'est du cinéma c'est comme avant des
combats de boxe ou quoi vous allez
release la prépa de femmes non non pas
par élise les prépas qu'on fait un
dingue allez c'est parti les amis aller
ok on a les blancs pour la première
j'aurais préféré qu'on commence avec les
noirs mais sans voix le système de
l'endroit à voir si la prépa passe ou
pas est-ce qu'on le cas y est ou pas on
va voir on va
ja du temps sur des 4/10 art il a dû
préparer la grob alors ça veut dire
qu'on a bien fait de choisir des quatre
îles fais 5
ok ça on n'a pas du tout préparé mais je
pense que c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle fois f4 et cavaliers ici
d'accord donc ils ont préparé ça pour
éviter pour éviter pour éviter le
système de l'undd ça c'est malin mais
d'un autre côté c'est assez dur à jouer
pour les noirs et je pense que ça peut
convenir à sarde
honnêtement c'est pas la prépa qui fait
le plus peur ils ont été obligés de
préparer un truc pour éviter ce que je
vous sarde habituellement donc c'est
assez cool j'espère que ça va mettre le
pion c4 quoi qu'il en soit pour prendre
le contrôle du centre ffu g3 alors là
par contre si reçu l'idée qu'on avait
joué avec f4 c'est pas forcément le top
mais c'est pas si mauvais on va voir
bessy seraient d'accord
il faut vraiment que
art s'adapte la sf cinq jeux landaise à
1200 ce pas tabou bas ils sont préparés
pour éviter ce que je vous sarde
habituellement après la hollandaise
c'est une petite ligne c'est assez malin
après c'est très dur à jouer avec les
noirs c'est pas sûr qu'ils s'en sortent
bien mais ça a été assez malin de là
de la part des norvégiens après ça
c'était difficile à deviner sans
vraiment voulu éviter le système de
l'undd custard maîtrise bien
après on avait parlé d'un leucate avec
sarah d'une fois j'avais montré mais bon
ils pouvaient pas se rappeler c'était
pas possible
bon allez c'est bien il fait cavalier
est roi il a compris que le f4 était une
erreur c'est très bien joué de la part
de sap qui s'est bien adapté il a mis le
fou en g3 donc c'est cool sur les
cavaliers h5 il a plus de foisches 4 et
l' avantage c'est que son adversaire
joue un truc qui ne connaît pas qu'il ne
maîtrise pas et pour des matches comme
ça parfois ça peut ça peut jouer des
énormes tour donc c'est plutôt cool en
vrai ça va c'est plutôt bien sorti je le
vois bien faire un dessin qu'à un moment
donné pour prendre le centre essar de
repartir sur les plans basique avec
cavaliers 2,5
parce que ouais c'est vraiment à double
tranchant ce qu'ils ont décidé c'est
très dangereuses qu'ils ont décidé de
faire avec avec les noirs c'est vraiment
très dangereux ainsi yvon l'ouverte
joue très peu pas tant que ça aurait du
coup là il fait food et si ce n'est pas
super ok ça sent qu'il sait pas quoi
faire avec les noirs donc il a réussi à
faire une surprise oui mais d'un autre
côté d'un autre côté il sait pas comment
jouer exactement derrière donc on a
réussi à les aller dribbler entre
guillemets c'est peut-être dommage de ne
pas avoir mis le cavalier ou 5 mais
c'est pas grave il se laisse l'échangé
il veut prendre 2 h et après attaqué le
roi donc en vrai je pense que
l'ouverture est plutôt en notre faveur
ici on va faire il va faire rage et
ouais ouais c'est plutôt en notre faveur
c'est vraiment plutôt en notre faveur
loups verts trouvent parfait parfait
parfait dauchez parfait et oui la
racaille norvégienne qui a voulu bien
voulu préparer qui a voulu préparer une
surprise mais qui ne connaît pas
complexe complet
la rocqué en face de la tour la sarre
die connaît le plan il sait qu'il faut
qu'il faut roquet est envoyé à les tours
sur la colonne h
ok je sais pas comment ça va se passer
mais en gros même s'il a joué même s'il
a joué de manière différente entre
guillemets libre et gratuit
pakistanais bien au-dessus bah ouais
parce qu'il a voulu dribbler en faisant
la hollandaise messar disent c'est qu'il
va falloir jouer avec g4 parce que ça on
en a parlé juste avant donc il sait
qu'il va faire grande tourrache quatre
tours h1 et envoyait g4 est ouvert le
roi ça peut
ah ça peut aller
le fou j'ai trois étaient bien joué et
là le grand roque j'ai dit à sartre
d'envoyer du gros rock c'était comme ça
pour amener les tours
normalement il ay là le plan il a le
plan vu à la maison
allez un peu de stress laquelle je vous
avoue la stresse un petit peu qu'est ce
qui va nous faire un grand roque parfait
parfait parfait
on a travaillé les plans on n'a pas
travaillé de trucs précis on a travaillé
le fou j'ai trois pour pour bate fou
prend h3h plongée 3 et et jouets écolos
nash qu'ils rentrent ils rentrent dans
les idées qu'on voulait jouer cavalier 4
ça s'est assez bien joué de la part de
ludwig
mais là si sarde pense aux cavaliers
cinq dames h5 ça peut aller très très
vite
il peut penser à fou prend 1,4 aussi et
cavaliers et cavalières 5 et damages 5
3-6 voilà damman h5 rossi voix cavaliers
5 tout reproche ses trois proches cette
dame h5 et tour h 1 ça peut être
maintenant quatre coups francs ça peut
être match tellement vite
ça peut être mat très très vite suivant
suivant comment on commence à jouer
assez chaud les amis qui a valu aux 5
après il ya peut-être des 6 1 je sais
pas si c'est vraiment bon mais ça peut
faire très mal
grâce à peu
faire très mal il y avoue prendre vous
prendre quatre ans premier cavalier là
il ya cavaliers là avec f3 avec g4 f3 il
ya pas mal d'idées mais en tout cas
ouais tour h4 c'est aussi dans le bon
rennes jld pourtour h tours tours h1 et
g4 ok il ay là il a un des plans il a un
des plans mon sarde parfait c'est
parfait pour le moment il sort sa partie
c'est exactement ce qu'on a vu avant
exactement le plan et je vais montrer
site mettre un pion f5 alors on avait à
peu près la même position avec le pion
en d5 à l'entraînement et je vais
montrer si tu fais g4 tuvalu ouvrir la
gueule c'est parfait pour le moment
c'est parfait la prépa caillet qui est
des cinq qui tombe c'est exactement ce
qu'on a vu prend il ce fait cai et ed
je lui ai dit amr ne comprend pas que ça
c'est foutu pour les noirs il comprend
pas que tu te fais maths et tout le
temps tu vas jouer ça il va rentrer là
dedans il ne comprend pas et oui hammer
une nouvelle fois qui va se prendre la
même a il a l'habitude d'un autre côté
aulas est terrible fantastique fantastic
il s'est bloqué le fourbe et 7 cross ça
marche mais fantastiquement bien
enfin je stresse un peu fou qui
finissent là faut qu'ils nous la met au
fond
mais il te la calle tête de ouf la moria
le stress là j'avais
cole j'avais comme la structure de pions
j'avais comme le truc avec olam heures
je le connais trop bien ludwig john
ludwig
voilà ça fait très très mal ça fait très
très mal
c'était tellement sûrs qu'ils
comprendraient pas le danger h si ça les
cavaliers de 5 kg 4 mais oui mon
cavalier en jeu les signes en russie et
au cavalier sinko pardon il va et le g4
c'est pas gagné 1 les gars mais là là
c'est sûr qu'ils en confiance il est en
confiance mon sarde l'aï c'est qu'on a
parlé de ça il connaît le carré le
simple tempo qui fait plaise roya même
des tours pour h6 qui peuvent se
regarder avec du damage sinko carrousel
à grosses gouttes à cause de g4 qui
arrive
ah bah oui il sait que ça a été préparé
l'américain et menaces cavalli g6
évidemment mais ça va être bloquée par
damas fils mais du coup il aura pas
cavalier celle ci sur accueilli 17 pour
ça si le voit et le cavalier ou 5 tempo
qui a fait mal
je stresse un peu la lega encore je vous
assure que je stresse encore violemment
ah non là je stresse là je stresse
vraiment là pour la peine c'est pas du
fake fera ça fait tellement plaisent de
rentrer de leur rentrée nouvelle prépa
je crois qu'on est vraiment trop fort en
prépa en fait l'école pakistanaise
l'école pakistanaise qui fait très très
mal mais il faut qu'il faut qu'on y
arriverait mais bon bah c'est un peu
plus que les autres si on fait le boulot
à carreaux qui dit tourache quatre tours
has the amazing plein really well played
abbas a été travaillé entre 18h et 19h
c'était travailler c'est pas de chance
pour icare ou le boulot est fait côté
français fait le travail en voilà on
fait le travail et c'est cool ça lui
fait tant qu du temps à laymont sarde
dame j'estime qu'au belges estiment qu
ça sent le coup de merde quand même pas
si mauvais que ça mais en fait il fait
j'ai 4 f 4g 5 seimat put s'y fait j'ai 4
f 4g 5 seimat en fait j'ai 4
sanou page et mettre un coup d'ordi là
je peux plus être vrai mais kim heger 4
et f4 g5 et il le match comme une merde
à quoi si le voit c'est vraiment dans
son règne fait g4 il est protégé par le
cavalier site choque pas là l'ordinateur
donne plus 6 50
bon après y'a pas davantage matériel
donc c'est pas si facile à gagner mais
en gros s'il envoie juste sur le roi
c'est hermine à dos là il est tellement
dans le driving site
mais bon sur j'ai quatre fois qu'ils
votent sur pions prend il doit prendre
en 4 avant effets retour pranger 4 après
[ __ ] c'est pas si facile justice en
matériel ouais mais parce que c'est la
position l écrasante les pièces noir
joue pas c'est exactement la même que
contre x cusset c'est exact
te ment le même truc que contre x cusset
ya cavaliers f3 aussi qui est pas idiot
d'ailleurs il ya tourage 5 kg 4 il ya un
f4 et g4 par non pas f3 mais toucher aux
pions il faut faire gaffe faire des
clips range étroit et quand on fait g4
et qu'on va vouloir faire f 4g cinq
forages ou un fou prend 1,4 aussi faut
faire f4 peut-être fou prend et g4 tout
cas il fait tourache 3 il veut jouer f4
et à protéger son pion c'est pas le
meilleur coup mais ça reste dans la
norme normalité cavani c6 maintenant
faut qu'ils fassent f4 du coup allée f
quattro à laymont sardet froid trop non
ok là il vient là il vient de faire de
conneries
ok il veut jouer f3 mais il n'est pas
allé le finir la trace à petit c'est
peut-être en train de tourner la game ok
mesdames f6 foot ils voient qu'ils
avaient 17 par contre un an mais il est
toujours bien il est toujours bien les
gars c'est pas cette chaussette choque
pas il est bien c'est pas
jouer ça va ça va c'est dans la
normalité c'est complet
la normalité l'autre est un peu moins
bien autant ça accélère on sait qu'il
joue pas très bien ludwig et les valses
à doit rester écrasant je vais vous dire
ok c'est plus un vin sur d'amd 8 mais je
veux dire par là que ça reste très
facile à jouer pour les blancs mais
juste la tourache croyais pas si bien
placé quand tu fais g4 ça laisse des
prises en f2 free peut y avoir des
variantes comme ça qu'ils peuvent gagner
aussi s'ils le voit il doit même si ça
les cavaliers 17 à l'écart
17 will cavaliers 17 où ils cavaliers 17
mai bien sûr monsieur allez petit ça ça
fait mal cavaliers 17
il a ma route et ça gagne pas la game
mais ça fait du bien
sa présence à présent tu combien leur
dis plus de 50 en fait tout à l'heure il
pouvait juste mater en force mais mais
là ok il a il a maintenant un avantage
matériel mais c'est cool parce que
ludwig non c'est plus un joueur
stratégie qui doit plus dominé dans ce
secteur du jeu et là ça se passe plutôt
bien pour sarde
donc c'est cool là faut qu'ils prennent
la tour ne faut pas que
ce f3 pour pas cependant un cavalier
pranger 3 on s'est un peu de chocs à
tous un à tout moment
2000 nettement parce que la la
l'ouverture était tellement meilleur que
ludovic qu'en fait ils démarrent la
partie à la sortie de l'ouverture il à
+4 quoi et il peut prendre et faire f3
éventuellement peut-être
j'ai parlé à plein de manières de
continuer on va voir ce qui fait quand
on a gagné là le côté préparation dans
cette partie après il faut finir un
cavalier f
ok il veut vraiment faire f3 sarde c'est
pas mauvais c'est pas mauvais c'est pas
mauvais du tout apprécié web avril a pas
il n'a pas été idéale mais bon il va
pouvoir faire f3 g4 faudrait claude
fasquelle et b4 pour poser des problèmes
et aller prendre le fou mais bon qualité
ça c'est bien joué de la part de l'ue
digne c'est un très bon coup de la part
du joueur américain
mais bon il peut faire à 3 à revenir
avec le cavalier ben on s'est mis un peu
en difficulté qu en vrai il va faire
quoi faire à trois je pense à mes gars
cavalli à 2,3 b1 et cavaliers ces trois
silos tu vois ça c'est terrible
f
3 il ya sept
de marloux qui va se prendre vite assez
fou ok pas vu je l'aï peut pas prendre
de la dame ce cas cavaliers f2 mais
cavalia 2 en fait ils auraient pu le
voir par hasard qu'elle prend du plomb
c'est bien vu cavale et des six tours h
quatre cavaliers g5 tout rachat
heureusement que je dis garate c'était
pas facile après un bain je suis un peu
vrai pas vu pas
free avait fait reculer la tour là quand
même je leur ai expliqué en fait le
problème sur cavaliers prend à deux
c'est que ça attaque et le roi le roi a
été obligé d'aller en d1 ou en b1 et sur
les n'importe quel des cases en fait il
fait fourchette et gagne la dame qu'est
la mine à tour en h4
j'aime pas trop mais bon il bloque un
peu ses tours il veut g4 et il veut tout
poussé en fait je t'attaque 4g 4 et où
poussaient dans la partie est très tendu
là il a une qualité de plus normalement
à leur niveau c'est vraiment un bel
avantage fois ci c'est encore un bon
coup ça peut mettre la pression sur
détroit et sa active le fou mal et faut
faire f 4g 4 et ou pousser la fauche
assez ce cavalier avancer vers le roi f4
turris bien ouais mais là il ya
cavaliers ou 4 le retour possible mais
il peut à mon avis quand même jouer pour
g4 et avancer après cavaliers 4 c'est
dur à voir il ya davantage du temps
aussi pour ça d'un tout petit peu mieux
au temps c'est stressant là là c'est
vraiment stressant ce qui a des
variantes avec cavalli ou quatre qui
fait cavaler h7 qui est acquis et bien
joué parce qu'il veut cavaliers f6 pour
enfermer la tour ils jouent des jolis
coups quand même ludwig
c'est dommage de ne pas l'avoir fini
dans l'ouverture où il a raté cavalia
fils où il a raté aussi à mais adam
prend merde et cavaliers à 6 à la fin et
il va perdre le pion détroit aux dames
prennent tôt plongé cette dame prend h5
sarde qui se présentent
sartre qui se présente avec une petite
idée tactique qui le sauva feu
heureusement d'apprendre des 3 onair d'
il va y avoir un cavalier 6 à la fin
olala quelle malchance il avait pas vu
en face à l'as vence assez terrible fou
prend des trois qui va attaquer le
cavalier et qui menacent fougue et
cavaliers six races et
eri bhl c'est terrible il est encore
tour h1 pour défendre mais bon tellement
dur à voir rester sur cahier g3 c'était
sûr et la cavalière si ce qui fait très
mal
prat c'est tellement dommage la position
de rêve mais c'est pas fini encore
cavaliers tour cavaliers contre tours
fou et le fou qui joue pas trop cavalier
fils qui est vraiment fort mais là il a
tellement de chance ludwig là sur cette
petite enchaînement dame prend des trois
a faim il a raté en fait ça va ça va
jouer
grand chose en tout cas ce qui est cool
c'est que le foot cases blanches à celui
qui l'a vu cavaliers insisté sur own on
en crève qu'ils fassent tourache quatre
tours prend un tour au 5 mai c'est dur
voilà ludique joue mieux en fait il a
mieux joué puisque sarda j'avais
vraiment une bonne position
il a vu par
chance mais c'est sa vraie réussite du
côté du joueur américain allait faut
prendre de la tour et revenir au 5 allée
s'est pas fait du tout tour cinq mois le
roi des deux c'est bien ils attaquent le
fou à les tours eu cinq attaques le pion
paraissait bien aller il faut à faut
faire quelque chose
franchement il a bien joué ludwig sardes
achevaient son niveau ouais ouais ça
redonne basse ardèche était vraiment
beaucoup mieux quoi mais après allez j'y
crois encore
donc c'est pas fini
pas fini du tout parce qu'ils gardent
encore les avantages du truc qu'on a
depuis le début en fait du fou qui joue
pas et sartre qui montre le roi le plan
des blancs je sais pas assez de bloquer
les noirs en fait peut-être si tu peux
faire roi bk 3 ces cinq malheureux
tout temps mais mon roi des cas tu auras
à cinq échecs malheureusement près qui
replace son cavalier peut-être et fait
roi b4 quand même n'est pas forcément un
bon coup mais qui n'est pas mauvais f5
ne faut pas échangé pour mc qui peut pas
rentrer plus loin ce hard avec son roi
l'autre a blindé mais il fait vraiment
une bonne partie ludique pour le monde
joue beaucoup mieux que son match
précédent qu'il veut pousser son pion ne
sais pas si grave
sarda mon avis qui va envoyer à 5 fu kid
rapport à qui trouvent ça roi prend ce
peut être pas mal il peut avoir droit à
6 3 prend 1,7 à l'efo qui bouge le
cavale qui le ramène par ici ouais
peut-être il l'a vu le bon plan fermez
le cavale
pour prendre aussi salée ça part de là à
laymont sarde qui ont gratuit allez
montions non il rate le pion gratuit en
un terrible
ok là faut qu'ils prennent 2d assez
terrible qui on en a raté et maintenant
il va y avoir foule et 5 fu f1 c'est
terrible le pion qui va filer à dame non
ils le voient pas le roi qui peut courir
il revient avec ton rois sardes
c'est terrible roi adverse qui va
rentrer mais bon ils rendent pas bien
loin
le roi de sativa landais si c'est chaud
en fait parce qu'il peut pas passer avec
son roi il fallait faire foufou b 5 fu
f-16 sa voix que le roi va pas plus loin
ça peut être très bon pour nous à les
rois des six fois fc3 issifou g8 3
issifou hc3 g7
il peut gagner comme ça ça ça peut être
un gain de la partie par chat sada du
fou et ludwig qui n'auraient plus rien
ici seraient bloqués aussi sarde
non il fait eu quatre [ __ ] un énorme
erreur énorme erreur énorme erreur non
s'il avait vu ça c'était gagné c'était
termine à dos ok maintenant il peut
prendre effet roi ici mais ça va être
une course de folie
ah non c'est vrai
trop d'erreurs la des deux côtés pour
pouvoir faire un pari quelconque ça fait
beaucoup trop d'erreurs des deux côtés
alessi voix qui bloquent toutes les
cases en fait ça peut aller le cavalier
bloc tous aller fc 1 que si c'est fini
voilà six voix f 5 g 4 6 7 6 9 7
et il arrêtera le pion au dernier moment
et qui avait allégé trois échecs mais
bon c'est irrationnel les finales à ce
niveau là c'est complètement irrationnel
il commence par six ce n'est vraiment
pas terrible mais bon ça peut faire le
taf quand même parce que sur fuji s'il
peut prendre ici et prendre des 5 allée
du coup prend ici et prend ici faut
surtout qu'ils prennent faut pas qu'il a
joués g4 et les pions passé on prend ce
pion oui il prend hockey l'autre a pas
vu qu'il avait des fous et karim
focaccia veut ça et maintenant prend lui
quand même oui il prend le pion à l'est
c'est cool parce que ça c'est bien
retourner ces traîtres
chaud mais là ça c'est bien tourner en
faveur de sardes
il faut qu'ils réussissent à pas perdre
l'option le pion ici allez la 1e set
envoie-t-on pions petit oui c'est jouer
mais ça peut finir en nul mais bon ça tu
es bien joué ça a été même temps
un jouet ou g6 il va sûrement prendre
ici je suis pas sûr qu'ils comprennent
que ça puisse être très dangereux de se
laisser manger le pion à l'essai coup le
roi et si c'est une erreur parce qu'il
doit avec leroy trouvait le con tre jeu
maintenant cavalier catherine tous
cavaliers ici une tout cavalier ici bien
jouer sarde
mais bon ça peut
être hyper dangereux parce qu'il va
faire arrêter le pion j'ai le pion h
pardon j'espère qu'ils fassent 3f 7,6
ferro f7 c'est bon je pense que roy g5
et c'est cet échange et repartir peut
être beaucoup plus dangereux on va voir
ça retient le temps en tout cas il à la
pause
c'est archi chaud mais il a une 26
contre 40 secondes et il place ses
pièces sur les bonnes cases il peut le
faire il peut le faire il peut le faire
c'est stressant mais il peut le faire
aller les amis on est tous derrière lui
la lire je veux des petites fusées là il
nous faut de la fusée à les cavaliers c7
c'est bien il joue pas le truc dangereux
il fait cavalier 3 auquel il aurait pu
faire caler ses sept sacrifier gagné la
finale mais maintenant cavalier f5
peut-être il veut taper espions surtout
pas qu'elle prend ses 4 mai cavaliers f5
pleutre éclairé oui pleutre éclairer
bien joué et cavalli prend h4 voilà ça
ça fait super plaisent parce qu'il
élimine le contre jeu principal de son
adversaire c'est bien joué mon sarde il
allait prendre le gros contre jeu de
ludwig et maintenant déjà on peut plus
perdre
elle est maintenant envoyer les pions
c'est bien c'est très
une 24 ces contrôles est allégé 5 1
voilà allez c'est bien le pion qui par
cavalli un f5 c'est pas mal aussi
into cavaliers g7 huit dames et une toux
cavaliers g7 huit dames en ces dames en
2 mai où ils tous 1,8 dames le 1/8 dames
et bien sûr mesdames et messieurs
ludovic w allez maintenant on l'a fini
un petit dams est 3e 5 3 et 6 tu sais le
faire sa dame de plus et roy e 5 3 et 6
into dame g7 et c'est hermine ado n'est
pas de stress pas de stress qu'elle
estime t il me fait des dingueries mais
bon il va prendre ces cartes je pense à
des français car est fait une autre dame
relaxe de toi ne fait pas ok juste prend
le fou comme ça et comme
ça et comme ça comment savoir
à toute âme
sept matches et voilà le petit 1 0
mais bon ça va
la prépa a tenu de justesse à une
nouvelle fois la prépa tenu de justesse
mais c'est vrai que la finale il est
parti avec un énorme avantage star
d'après son adversaire a craqué mais
c'est vrai que ce fou on a réussi une
nouvelle fois limité
la prépa qui a bien payé une nouvelle
fois les plans qui ont fait plaisir non
mais là il y avait du stress
bon la deuxième partie est ce que la
deuxième prépa va pas c est ce qu on
fait un deux sur deux les amis ce soir
fêtons 1 2 sur 2 sur les prépas allez
allez deuxième
pas et
et on est et on gagne le match c'est
hyper stressant mais du coup merci pour
pour les vingt mille 20 heures qui
suivent le match vous pouvez aussi
suivre ma chaîne perso si vous le
souhaitez twitch pointé vsh bitstream
si vous leur plus d'échec je mets le
lien dans le chatt j'en profite
ça fait plaisir si égalité il ya quoi il
ya un armageddon
mais à c'est plutôt c'est plutôt cool à
il a gagné la première pas de stress
j'ai dû écrire
bon c'est cool ouest état
ouais c'est mérité on
ludwig a bien bien bien mieux joué que
contre logique 1 le niveau de jeu est
bien plus élevée ces tests est évident
en fait qui jouerait mieux à lui dire
en fait il a raté la première balle de
match je dirais sarde la première occase
il a raté quant à la sortie l'ouverture
mais il a réussi à maintenir l' avantage
du cavalier contre le fou regarde et en
fait dans cette position on va le mettre
un peu plus loin le fou noir réussissent
et pas du tout à jouer
là ils avaient des plans aussi avec
cavaliers f1 qu'avait cavaliers chien
qui avait l'air 3 kg 5
bon allez il est un peu de chocs mais en
fait on a réussi à maintenir l' avantage
dessous de cases blanches qui joue pas
et à leur niveau même si sarde a raté un
gain
en début de partie malgré ça en fait ce
problème là est trop dure à régler à
leur niveau à long terme il a quand même
réussi à la passer à droite par la sar
entre les gays moi le problème je dois
lui écrire c'est pendant les games que
j'ai pas le droit c'est tout à fait
normal
allez
à
voilà je
non
bon
du coup
alors est ce qu'on a bien prévu ok
c'était la double prépa on avait bien
prévu et oui et oui c'était à l'api nous
c'était à lapinous grand prix c'était
l'un ou l'autre
et oui pas de chance pour le joueur
américain
les deux prêts pas été là bah oui
c'était grand prix ou à la pin's et les
deux choses qu'on ait préparé kayed pas
deux
en ce1 bas à préparer la ligne ça a été
révisée juste avant la partie c'est
dommage pour le joueur américain
c'était l'un ou l'autre
c'était grand prix ou ou à l'api on est
un peu plus regardé le grand prix parce
que c'était plus dangereux mais la
lapine été travaillé aussi est issu déjà
dès le deuxième coup c'est pas de chance
alors ça par contre on n'a pas fait il a
illico il connaît pas non plus en face
on pensait
sarah grand prix quand même plus
regarder grand prix du coup on avait
regardé ces quatre ici plutôt on va voir
bon
pensez plus qu'ils joueraient c4 du coup
il a fait des quatre ans premier qui est
jouable aussi on va voir ce qu'ils font
n'est plus le grand prix était plus
dangereux du coup on avait eu on avait
moins
il faut faire quoi alors ces femmes qui
avaient préparé ça mais je pense qu'il
faut prendre prendrait dès 6 ans fait et
ça va
en prise était le plus dangereux donc
avait plus regardées il aurait pu
préparer ça j'en avais plus regarder ces
quatre si le jouet mais là normalement
des six il va trouver puis on prend et
aux 6 normalement il connaît ce plan et
reprendre du fou en d6 on a regardé
aussi ce genre de plan et il le fait
mais c'est sûr c'était là où l'autre
ouais
ça c'est sûr qu'à paris abonde moi j'ai
dit j'ai dit à sartre de bosser un ces
fameux café la ligne moi j'ai surtout
revu les blancs avec avec avec sarde et
on a un peu revue les noirs on a surtout
vu les idées sur sur le grand prix parce
que ça semble être le plus dangereux est
vite fait la lapine avec cette variante
là et on a vu à bord avec ses 4 mais ça
revient au même l'idée de faire puis on
prend aussi ses reprendre voilà sarde à
mon avis va développer les pièces là
après c'est plus est plus vraiment
théorique mais le truc c'est d'avoir le
plan est à la position était sorti a
aucun danger avec les noirs
vous voyez la différence on est sortis
de l'ouverture avec les blancs au final
après à la sortie des plans à plus hélas
ces dames à 5 int où ils tous dame prend
les cinq la racaille qui va devoir
tomber
voilà dans la machine que ces cadeaux
emprunt pakistanaise au revoir merci au
revoir merci non
le choot ça commence à être chaud qu
adama 5 c'est facile quand même manqué
première erreur première
1 mais bon c'est pas si grave parce que
fout des cinq dames 1 4 c'est très
faible
maintenant il va devoir faire [ __ ] en
c6 france et 6 il va regagner tempo sur
la dame
ok là c'est le stress c'est évidemment
mais bon il sort quand même super bien
de l'ouverture au kef où prend en france
et 6 c'est bien il faut quand même
comprendre du fou hein ça gagne un temps
sur la dame
il faut développer ok c'est pas assez
pas gagnant mais bon on va dire que la
halle à l'ouverture s'est bien passé il
n'avait pas préparé n'était mieux
préparés que lui ce n'est pas vraiment
une pièce manque et où l'accueil c'est 7
qu'est ce que c'est que ça à
ok là ça devient un peu n'importe quoi
c'est un peu irréel des deux côtés la
est trop de pression d'un mât cinq
cavaliers c3 qui reprend ses droits et
encore fou prend ses six prix s'est
située en france et 3 mais là un coup
comme dame français 3 gagne le pion est
là c'était termine à dos mais là les
deux je crois que les deux fonds ont
beaucoup fatigués ils ont été un peu en
surrégime dans la première la cave et
laissé 7 oh la la
cet enchaînement d'erreurs la série
bleue mon mal joué enfin c'est terrible
irak le damas un qui fait n'importe quoi
c'est pas
civ olala cet enchaînement mauvais coup
il a pas vus dame prime 3 c sur place et
le stress panique ouais il avait le
damas cinq cadeaux oh là là et tours b 8
on sait que des coûts catastrophique là
pourquoi il fait pas d
pour pousser à la partie est
catastrophique 1
en non là c'est le stress allez allez
il pousse le pion faire moi cette
position tu fais aussi c'est tu joues
fait aussi ce pour protéger en fait il
attend depuis tout à l'heure qui
prennent je sais pas ce qu'il fait
trois n'a pas vu dame prend à wright
choc il faut développer
c'est cela
si c'est pas mal allez ça va
si si si rentrer dans sa partie ça va ça
va aller c'est pas c'est pas dramatique
il a tout défendu la rien perdu il ya
rien de moins et même si les blancs sont
objectivement mieux c'est dur à jouer
qu'ils voient des plans comme cali ces
trois cavaliers 4 mm là c'est pas très
grave et c'est vraiment
bien cessa pas l'air d'être un coup très
convaincant faut juste qu'ils voient qu
on prend pions prend la tour et défendu
y fait des cinq maintenant ok du coup il
ferme la colonne des haies et du coup
tour d un coup un peu superflu il va
faire foule cette rock ok il ya eu pas
mal d'erreurs fait côté côté sarde mais
là il ya beaucoup d'erreurs fait côté
ludwig à trois ça n'appartient pas du
tout à la position a juste fawcett rock
et on souffle un peu
juste qu'il voit que sur d'alger trois
robes fois-ci s'il aura qu'un value8 ça
c'est dur ça c'est dur à voir s'ils
voient que
value8 c'est marrant parce qu'on en a
parlé mais on a parlé du fouet fuite on
n'a pas parlé d'une défense comme ça je
lui ai dit si tu peux défendre g7 sais
rien pourquoi trois mauvais parce que ça
accompli rien à 3 faut qu'ils voient
rock
value8 c'est dur à voir honnêtement
c'est dur à voir oh non il s le pion g7
c'est catastrophique et l'aurait dû
faire au pire fois fit ou quoi que ce
soit mais il doit pas laisser le pion g7
en l'air
ça c'est vraiment
trophique au québec a trait au temps
catastrophique b cinq mois qu'il faut
vraiment qu'il va croquer jouables un
d'apprendre
d'un projet c'est très impressionnant
aussi là les deux jouent très très mal
cette partie ils ont tout donné sur la
première g5 voilà c'est ok mais j'ai 5
c'est mieux que de se prendre dame prend
g71 le stress jouant évidemment g5 c'est
mieux de se prendre dame prend g7 ce que
mentale pions allez bon là
alors
qu'est ce que ça va
son roi tu vas faire rock quand même il
fait f5
il ya aussi l'autre fait prise en
passant fou prend ouais mais bon ça va
ça perd rien et c'est chaud no - ça
ces dames pranger set c'était vraiment
catastrophique l'appui on prend prise
honnêtement ça joue en carélie c7 défend
hockey serait très mauvais pour les
noirs mais c'est pas un avantage
gravissime ses actifs
tf 4 c'est très mauvais maintenant il
peut faire j'ai quatre et h 5 h quatre
faux qui ferme la position ici allez
droit et du cou et du coup il peut être
très tranquille il fait ici c'est
dommage mais ça va ok f4 c'était
vraiment fait parce que du coup il n'a
pas pris le pion et ça permet à saab de
bloquer sur cases blanches regarder il a
sont fous de cases noires donc il a le
bon fou il manque un peu des spasmes et
mais les blancs n'ont pas du tout
utilisé leurs menaces
après le plan qu'il faudrait voir c'est
qu'elle va aller à 8 qui avait b6 crise
et 4 1 mais bon ça j'en ai pas parlé
parce que c'est impossible mais bon il
s'est hissé bien remis après une série
de coups vraiment catastrophique de sa
part ludwig ya une vraie possibilité de
prendre les devants mais il a
complètement raté et maintenant
maintenant la position est très tendu
très complexe et s'il fait g4 eemeaa
serait fou h4 pour gagner la dame en
plus mes cavaliers à 8 qu'ils aient
baissé ce qui a laissé 4 c'est un joli
plan un peu devant autant hockey en
francs confiance
confiance le temps ça va une minute
d'avancé l'autre a fait quelques très
mauvais coup que ça c'est bien joué de
la part de son adversaire
parce qu'il veut rentrer en h5 c'était
un des problèmes d'un autre côté on peut
faire j'ai quatre damage 5 3 17 et on
chassera la dame et ça va tout à fait
pour les noirs on va être à mon niveau
tu peux à mon avis plus trop perdre ici
parce que j'ai 4 damage 5 3 17 on sait
qu'on a besoin d'une nulle 1 et on va
faire ça on va échanger les dames et
même s'ils ramènent le cavalier ans et 5
on le prendra et c'est tous fermés
partout ça peut encore être dangereux
faut faire gaffe mais a il a fait roi 17
direct c'est pas mal joué au roi 17
direct c'était le bon plan c'est la
bonne case pour le roi il peut pas se
faire attaquer sur blanc bref
roy d'accord il faudrait voir ce plan
mais c'est dur et puis on prend g4 mf4
j'aime pas évidemment mais bon c'est pas
si mauvais fait son roi et bizarrement
bien placé et maintenant fausse taxe sur
la colonne j'ai au kef où j'ai cinq ans
à varilhes ont ils à trouver un plan
c'était ça qui est important
le problème c'est que si l'autre voie ça
ça peut être catastrophique mais c'est
pas du tout dit qu'il le voit est encore
catastrophique ça peut être chiant mais
en fait les deux voies passé fait ces
deux casa sont les deux cas sur lesquels
on veut rentrer pour les blancs c'est ça
qu'on va mettre en rouge et pour les
noirs c4 mais c'est dur parce que la
case naturelles développement c c 3 pour
le cavalier la ffu des deux allait là
faut qu'ils mettent les pièces sur la
colonne j'ai maintenant et qu'il attaque
ça me paraît être un plan assez simple
je pensais le meilleur plan dans le
règne des plans qu'ils puissent trouver
qui peut avoir ce que cavalia 8 des 6 et
4 il aura pas ça serait vraiment fort
bref on prend des deux qui prend des
deux ils trouveraient par pur hasard ce
serait dégueulasse qui a valu à 8 km et
6 4 6 4 c'est tellement dur
à
des de ses katas les dames
5comment si c'est pour dames g5 derrière
j'accepte ok bon ça va assister pour une
idée c'est juste
par pur hasard l'aude va trouver qui a
et b 3 qui a laissé cinq quoi c'est
tellement relou mais bon il va faire
tourner
de fait c'est bien il est dans le plan
de jeu que j'ai donnée d'attaquer son
roi jeudi claude choquet et la petite
chance qu'il a c'est que sur cavaliers
c5 son cavalier défend les deux cases
ok vas-y tour g8 ok j'ai trois îles
f4 je pense à merde
fonctionner autant préféré qu'il fasse
tourner ses huit into cavaliers à 8 mais
il va jamais trouvé ça ok et une tour
c'est un cavalier à 8 mais ça et ce qui
va le trouver
en fait j'avais une variante assez sale
de f4 tour c'est un tour ses huit dames
c6 parce que là c'est autant prince est
soit les noirs gagne soit les blancs
mais il avait salut de vignes qui
gagnaient pour les blancs du coup
c'était important de faire tourner ses
huit en premier c'est cool
il a eu le sens du danger du coup le
cavalier blanc qui va venir en f3 c'est
ce que j'allais vous dire ça tu vas
mettre à mon avis adam angers 4 il va
trouver qu'il a avalé à 8 par hasard
peut-être mais faudra voir qui avait b6
qui haïssez 4 voilà normalement la dame
des anges et 4 mais c'est cool parce que
lecavalier s'est éloigné de la case c5
ouais
est il a ramené son cavalier lecavalier
des deux au lieu de lui donner le bon
plan ça lui a donné le plan cavaliers 3
qui est complètement pour av
parce que maintenant saddam est attachée
à la défense du cavalier et sartre quand
il va faire f4 la dame et plus connecté
avec le pion g3 donc le cavalier juste
horrible sur cette case
le cavalier juste horrible
non surtout rien il va pas jouer
cavalier ou huit
une reine il va jouer cavalier à 8 tu
vas le voir mais carey la vie de kate
qui est le cas des alliances etc at il
est tellement monstrueux mais il a aussi
le plan f 4 1 note sarde et là
maintenant comme je vous dis le cavaly
est très mal placé la séquence cavaliers
f3 dame g4 est complètement en faveur de
sardes aller et il est
ça peut aller au bout les amis oui si
monstrueux en c4 dans ces quatre ans
fait le cavalier contrôle beaucoup de
cases et en plus il ferme la colonne
c'est que quand tu vas voir ta tour ans
et 8 tu vas ouvrir quand tu veux pas ce
cavalier il peut jaillir à n'importe
quel moment n'importe où il est protégé
il ferme une colonne et il te laisse les
mains libres pour jouer de ton côté
scangos et les blancs qui voudraient
jouer là plutôt je dirais ce cadran en
17 et les noirs qui veulent jouer ici en
mettant un cavalier en c4 tu bloques la
colonne ces taupes tient une pièce ultra
active un genre une genre de pieuvre et
en plus ça te laisse les mains libres
pour attaquer de l'autre côté
donc ça fait tellement de choses ce qui
a valu en c4 voilà je pense que ça
devrait aller
on a repris le on a repris le dessus
cavalier lilian thuram way et 4,20
contre devrait y fit il fait sa
puissance f4 ya pas d'un problème 4 d'un
premier katia clouage ils le voient un
stand sassard normalement ça normalement
le voit instanz dames 3 c'est un gros de
choc
et oui vu in stands par sarde c'était
sûr en fait d'un f2 et maintenant cif et
du sal
il va faire pions prend pions prend et
tour f8 même pas échanger les dames et
matraqué ça peut faire très mal
en tout cas il fait pions prend sur dame
prend va pas échanger faudrait se
décaler et gagner la dame est là
peut-être un tour et fuite en premier
mais je pense qu'il va prendre g3
c'était sûr en fait prises prise prise
roi f2 et tour g8 normalement pour
protéger la tour est menacée tour j'ai
deux îles
gic mais la position aurait pu faire
plus on aurait pu faire plus mais on
n'est pas si mal dont g8 jouer est ok
juste il faut trouver ce plan s'il
trouve ce plan c'est fini tout reprend
g1 et on place le cavalier ses dadas
vous celui là qui est pas mal aussi mais
cavaliers c4 en plus tu gagnes le pion à
3 et tu gagnes toute la partie tout seul
donc il prend du cavalier là il faut
trouver ça et c'est terminé
mais il va pas trouver
mais là
avec le roi pour fermer la colonne voilà
olalalala de nouveau dû y aura échec à
ces terribles ce roi qui part à non il
avait une telle en bonne position il a
échangé les dames il fallait pas il
fallait continuer à attaquer la la
finale elle est loin d'être simple et il
a juste jamais vu ce plan en fait
après la sas
facile à leur niveau 1 focalisé cette
cavale et f5 je pensé revenir sur la
colonne c'est avec la tour sud qui sert
à rien quelle horreur il voit pas
paris voit pas comment jouer son
cavalier c'est terrible grasset sûr
qu'il va la perdre
je suis dégoûté reste très mauvais plans
[ __ ] cette planque atteint maintenant
la torah
h7 il se fait marcher dessus oh non au
nom c'est incroyable à l'autre joue
super bien là
oh là là j'étais tellement gagnant
encore croyez ta cavale ie8 est de
gagner la partie
il est
rédiger cette carafe 5 d'être dedans et
c'est pas perdu encore c'est pas tout
perdu c'est pas tout à fait perdu parce
que les pions sont fixés il aurait
encore le pion à 6 ce serait nulle
cavaliers g6 c'est pas un bon coup allez
faut qu'il trouve ce plan en fait c'est
juste qu'il faut qu'ils trouvent ce plan
mais pas
il est en train de le trouver trop tard
malheureusement qu'est ce qui fait plus
d'un et propose nul et un autre qui
trouvent le bon plan alain le roy qui
rentre en effet si c'est terminé et
cavaliers flicaille prend aussi ce
terrible
bhl
puisse-t-il échange des cavaliers
mieux que cet élan il joue vraiment bien
là il était juste à un implant la deûle
à faire un terrible ça s'est joué à ça
c'est joué ici en fait s'il fait jusqu'à
val est à 8 c finito enfin je sais pas
s'ils gagnent aussi fait nul mais en
fait il peut plus perdre le cavalier
arrivants c4 cédait d' allah
maj 3 autour f8 c'était fini tout
reprend j'ai trois essais m'attendait en
fait il aurait fait d'un match 3 au lieu
de touré fuite c'était d'être de celle
d'ed détour pranger 3 et abandon suite
en fait c'était vraiment abandon direct
star h3
en injectant
match 3
bon
ah ça c'est dommage il y aura de regret
à ce regret la et à leur gré et il ya le
regret quand même dame à 5
parce que c'est pas du tout sûr enfin ok
là ce serait très bien passé enfin sur
d'amd de il y avait du fois ci c'est un
temps pêche le rock est à ça va
dans cas samedi
non
j'écris
cbo
ce
dans mon cas
donc
donc ces best of ah ouais
voir ce que ça donne
non
peu stressant qui a bien joué c'est
dommage il a raté l'occasion
en avoir une autre
à voir s'il envoie alors ce qu'il vous
tarde à l'être
ça va envoyer à hilal et noir sardes ont
pensé qu'ils avaient les blancs qui va
repartir sur la même
ok il a fait pousser 4 à la place hockey
du coup qu'ils avaient libéré six four
b3 et des six ans c'est cool parce que
du coup le norvégien s'est préparé
pendant la pause où il a préparé les
regarder un truc mais mais il n'en sait
pas plus que vous c4 et du coup ça les
gars c'est pas forcément une bonne idée
de revoir son répertoire juste avant une
partie parce que du coup la ffu b5 et à
mon avis ça peut faire à 6 et reprendre
du pillon et ça peut aller donc en fait
il a fait un fou ou un coup de fouet qui
n'était pas super utile il a regardé
l'analyse ouais mais bon ça va ça va pas
bien loin ça parce que du coup il a
refait foulée cinq coups d'après il sait
pas quoi jouer à l'essai 5
un cruel a pas plus de temps parce que
là en fait s'ils font nulle sari match
donc on va voir
des six allez ça va ça se passe il faut
qu'ils sortent le fou devant et sajoo 1
c'est une position compliquée la cgeci
ça va ça se joue ça se joue complètement
fou g5 c'est malin comme coup mais m'ont
pas si grave
oui allez noir
ça doit être les points de groupe
j'essaie d'accord ils rejouent parce
qu'il ya un partout un ok là faut qu'il
fasse gaffe sur roc l'appui on prend des
6es prises ici donc j'avoue qu'ils
soient hyper prudent
pour défendre ok au moins il a vu il a
vu l' attaque mais bon il va se prendre
karellis ces trois peut-être et je suis
un peu inquiet dam des deux ce qui va
jouer rock je suis un petit peu inquiet
là les gars je vous cache pas là je suis
même très inquiet je suis
inquiet la position à 20 mais faut
trouver agie si swatch 4g 5 ce qui va
jamais trouvé il va faire rock et fois
ci ce qu'il prend maintenant et qui est
peut-être bien joué en fait ça parce que
sur cavaliers prend il va faire f 6 et
il n'a pas vu ou là c'est une pièce ça à
laymont sarde f6 cf6 il va le jouer
ok ça a choqué côté américain il faut
pas paniquer f6 qui est processus d'amd
si c'est iggy rase tout ils rasent la
maison allait juste m6 a laissé jouer de
53 ans avait séduit 5 + 0 sec
frost saleté cdu + 0 sec tracé salle de
faire du sec quand amis du rajout les
parties d'avant il n'y a pas de
crémant ah ouais mais là il se met à mal
autant il a peut-être pas prévu qu'ils
avaient pas d'un crémant c'est terrible
mais ça c'est sale de faire ça de chasse
comme là honnêtement après ça sorte de
lire les règles aussi de voir comment ça
joue mais bon avec des joueurs amateurs
six amis du rajout tu gardes du rajout
tu gardes plus de secondes quoi ce que
les règles ils les ont changé en fait
avant il y avait du rajout ils ont
enlevé ben il faut prendre ses six
essais une pièce ok mais larmes là c'est
armageddon en fait parce qu'en cas nul
ça relou c'est complètement différent et
cavale et prend 1,7 à les sardes
pourquoi il prend de la dame maintenant
il ya un coût de dames qui peut être
chiant aux noms ont prouvé la paperie du
cheval
pourquoi il n'a pas pris du chevalement
leïla deux pièces de plus mais ça va en
fait on a un coût de réussite sur dan d2
il ya fou aussi socquet cavaliers
prendre 7
pour la ces deux pièces de plus les gars
non il ya cavaliers diack a rayé des 5
pourquoi il a laissé ça c'est terrible
de laisser ça ok il a tour à cette
heureusement mais c'est hyper dangereux
il ya tour dès maintenant
ohlala pourquoi il a laissé sa robe plus
vite sort des clous âge auras les durs à
jouer fou prend b2
elle est dure à jouer encore pour les
noirs ils auraient rockets il aurait
fait roi et c'est tout rock c'était fini
tôt il n'a pas osé wife c'est toi mais
tu dois pas te tu dois pas de clouer
quoi tu dois jamais de cloud est allé x
3 il fait bouger cette loi va faire
tourner un hoquet ff8 tu dois faire et
ça défend entière
être c'est cool c'est cadeau allez faut
vraiment aller enlève cette année c'est
cool
allez ça c'était vraiment une faute de
son adversaire ce que ça donne ça donne
à sarrebourg wife 7 qui fait du bien
allé il ya deux pièces de plus va aller
mon sarde
désolé je suis un petit peu stressé un
pur pour notre compatriote
mais là c'est cool il a réussi à tout
défendre c'était pas propre propre mais
il se retourne sur ses pas il faut
encore jouer quelques bons coups de
défense mais au moins il a il a gagné
deux pions au passage il a vraiment deux
pièces net
ok il laisse le pion g5 on sait pas
pourquoi mais c'est pas si grave
une nouvelle fois joué un peu n'importe
quel coup il faut juste qu'ils se
stabilise
allez il faut sortir les pièces h si
c'est bien
ils se donnent des cases sont rois qui
respire mais bon c'est dommage a si
bolat par leurs maîtres de rage où ils
veulent vraiment faire ils veulent
vraiment que ça finisse en mode
n'importe quoi comme dans les battles
mois il a rattrapé autant elle est
maintenant faut faut développer faut
développer les pièces cavaliers des 5
c'est encore bien joué allez une 26
contre une
24les ami andreas qui prend l'avantagé
au temps maintenant à l'efo qui tangue
du temps l'américain il faut développer
à les fous pk tu gagnes un tempo sur la
tour encore allez sortez pièces sortent
et pièces pourraient tout recettes bien
joué aussi
et il trouve les coûts là il trouve les
coûts sarde tour s'est très bien joué il
va faire encore tant que du temps à
ludwig qui veut surtout pas échanger les
pièces là il joue un petit peu plus vite
à maintenant il prend il prend une
quinzaine de secondes avant ça les fous
prend sortait pièce aller plus vite plus
vite nom propre en prend plus vite
pourquoi il prend du cavalier je sais
pas c'est irréel de prendre du cavalier
ne pas sortir le fou mais bon c'est fait
développe des pièces faut juste
développer h5 c'est bien c'est bien il
accélère il a mis il a mis la
surmultipliée avec tous les coups il
gagne un peu de gagner un peu de temps
mon sarde
allez tu prends deux fois ses pions
gratuit il est en train d'autres chocs
l'américain il est en train de choc
allez reprend du pied ont bien joué
sarde tu reprends g4 c'est bon il ya de
moins en moins de danger les pièces qui
disparaissent allez prends h4 mais oui
mon sarde
mais oui allez maintenant qu'un rayon
des 5 c'est parfait tourache trois
échecs vas-y vas-y tu prends un f4 mois
il est en train d'exploser le joueur
américain à lequipe.fr 4 sur échec où il
monsieur est fou c'est 5 sur échec et
tourache un échec et mat c'est ma tante
3 les gars c'est ma tante 3 à laymont
sarde
il est temps de faire payer la banque là
il est temps de faire payer la banque
ça va au bout allez-vous ses cinq tours
h un hoquet calais détroit qui prendra
sa gagne aussi et tour h 2 il va monter
le roi ok il va juste gagner le roi tour
contre roy et c'est gagné 3 [ __ ] quel
génie et voilà les amis c'est gagné ah
ça fait plaisir ça fait plaisir c'est
gagne à dos c'est hermine ados ludwig
éliminé essarts d'âge qui file en finale
hikaru w à et bah voilà voilà qui fait
plaisir les amis voilà qui fait plaisir
mais bien sûr mesdames et messieurs le
joueur français qui se qualifie
rennes ce qui au bout de sa vie ah bah
oui mais bon et oui mais bon c'était sûr
il a fait le malin ludwig avant le match
il a beaucoup travaillé avec avec les
norvégiens avec 1 meur avec magnus mais
ça n'a pas suffi alors
astique bas s'est bien passé après la
prépa de la première dans les dents les
sicilienne
ça s'est assez bien passé aussi en
réalité est fantastique
ça mérite un slot in good game grâce à
fait
un bon ce fait le petit raid et puis on
discute et on
on discute on discute un peu après merci
à tous d'avoir suivi je m'envoie un raid
sur ma chaîne et on retrouve dans
quelques secondes a tout de suite les
gars